so those you are over there we're going
to stop and say y equals now I can draw
any of the graphs that I showed you in
this one ok so just as an example I'm
going to compare such a picture of all
of them this morning
all right let's Cory not we'll do 10 n
if you get a function over here on the
right hand side over there you can see
this treat this chart minute some other
stuff
where my tree tab is right there so I
think an X now your graph might not look
like mine so there's one thing I haven't
changed on every one which is this scale
okay so I want you to look carefully
look up at the board see the top right
hand corner there's a stamp right there
geez here so what I'm going to do is
show you what all of my numbers are and
why they're there okay the first thing
is why should go from the bottom to
green see that you know I probably reads
right now is that generating yeah I
always play reading A to B in time so
now so quick it over degrees for me okay
secondly I've got my y-axis I mean these
numbers only not the approximate that's
about negative 4 that's about 4 so go
ahead and change those let me get an X
and it goes all the way up and down
yeah so let's just I'll make it
convenient for you so I'll just write
minus 4 for now we have a look at the
x-axis you have to change this quite
significantly I'll do mine strong just
to make it like a B minus 360 to 360 and
in addition to that over on the right
you can see it as step now by default I
think it just stepped up in there like
10 should be the hundreds just decimal
stuff but we're in degrees 360 degrees
180 90 those are the kinds of values
that are important to us
so the step is how often it puts one is
vertical line okay
so change that to 90 and then you should
be pretty much there's no change
Peter relax based on the government okay
so the other Geographic pipeline to the
manatee what is it yes all right
now in addition to 10x underneath that
now let's also draw the graph
ir is du which is y equals to 10
now what it does is the order colors for
you so minor might have black and red
you don't might be blue or green well
I've no idea what it gives you but can
you see what's the difference between
regular 10x that's my black one and two
cannons which is a vertical stretch it's
steeper instance okay
in fact if you zoom in a little bit
that's far enough
this essentially you can see 0 and 90 at
a reasonable level of detail okay
now the first thing you should know if
you never get the money because the
vertical isotope ok now this won't draw
vertical asymptotes for you
automatically but you can if you want to
do it manually you can go x equals 90
and if you wanna be fancy you can change
it to a dotted lines no there you go so
that shows you the asymptotes but not
required
I just want you to recognize interfere
now importantly do you remember the 10x
graph it needs a point to scale what's
the point scale we usually do we usually
pick x equals what if I degree which is
there see that half way buddy and if X
is points are degrees then 10x is one
visit but look at to tenants where is it
it's okay at two because it is stretched
Red Queen Donald does that make sense
okay good so you can do all these kinds
of comparisons get written down in the
same way if you want you could go back
and you could put in cuz X my broken
brackets below once
there we go and you can compare that to
y equals half of it so that's the same
as cos x divided by two again how to
look at how it compares the black ones
my original one you recognize it it does
the user waving up and down with cosign
does what's the difference between that
and half cost and how to describe it
verbally yeah sure
hearken to the heart the Institute we
have it sort of compressed down right
all the other things are said the
Internet's are the same the frequencies
are the same but it's just that vertical
dimension okay so now destroy those get
rid of let me show you what I really
want to show you which you have play
with okay this one we will again sign so
what I'm going to do is write y equal
and the point is if you want to change
frequency and which is phase you can
change those by any numbers your life
not Johnson one two or 70 degrees so to
say anything you want I want you to
follow a template online I have to write
y equals a sine
be X plus C and then on the outside of
the bracket
I'm going to say plus D okay now if you
type that exactly as I type it then it
should offer up many options for sliders
you see that do you hit blue picks up
all boxes okay how are we looking at
okay what I need you to do is before we
muck about with it can you see a bubble
of the equations and sliders where they
are is that gear icon of the top tab
that body what I want you to do is if
I'm remembering correctly go to the see
this once you know see if you've got
some boundaries and again first step
what I want you to put in is zero 360
and for this step let's put the 30 so
should look like this
can you get that no that's just to see
the rest of the must one okay are you
there okay once you click done I want
you to do one more thing which is to if
you can carefully take the slider for
this last one D and Q just moving from
zero its continent one just shift it a
little bit to the left until it zero
also this C equals one make a zero so
now what we're looking at what it is
this is y equals 1/5 X plus zero plus
zero this is the familiar say term which
possibly rings the bell board starting
zero goes up 180 Senate for 360 are you
happy
your exponent now funded you a couple
look at a a is is coefficient right out
the front over here right so if you take
your mouse and you slide a let's write
it to the - whoa okay what you should
notice is oh right what am I taking I'm
taking it with you I'll just stretch it
out vertically okay you can bring it
back down to one and your amplitude
returns to or your rage return to
negative ones one have a look at me
before you start to muck around with it
what do you expect to happen when I
change B and make this number bigger I'm
[ __ ] around with the NA Cervenka
secret of the deal I'm tossing it right
so now I take an output onto B and just
slide it to the right and do you see the
frequency in the period changing that is
that yes okay bring it back two three
back to one okay now we see I said go
for north of 360 why's that because I
want to talk in terms of angle this is a
phase shift right so now can use that
what's happening
if I leave it at night Shh
can you see this is plus 90 degrees so I
have moved ninth reason to God left eye
so gone this way by the way when you
move side 90 degrees to the left when
you chose it to love a precise license
to cultivate okay so I've got that and
you can see I can keep on shifting as
long as I want and I'm going to be
further and further and further to the
level I stopped a physically what
because once you're there you can
superior so if you want to go further
then you just come back the mirror and
you go and it's exactly the center all
right last one what's happening together
what a missus what's changing this is
going to change
Eric your boss oh yeah it's the vertical
position right so now if you move this
around you can see what was another work
all you're doing is taking it up and
down right so if I put it back to zero
let me take you okay good that's a
regular sonographic but of this morning
I think we grab this plus one and we
like that look do you see what happens
to the range
just like we predicted the range is not
negative 1 to 1 anymore is 0 to 2 you
see that's where it is happen yes so you
can look about with all of these as much
as you like it gets a bit trippy if you
do too many ok come on there we go there
it just isn't